et
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre émission
sur la langue des signes
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer de
nouveaux signes pour améliorer la
communication avec les sourds et si on
essayait d'aller à la boulangerie
bonjour madame bonjour je suis sourde
vous êtes sword
je voudrais une baguette s'il vous plaît
vous voulez un croissant un croissant
non ça c'est un croissant une baguette
elle n'a pas compris
ce n'est pas un croissant ce n'est pas
un pain au chocolat
ce n'est pas pas aux raisins c'est
facile c'est simple une baguette on va
voir on va essayer une baguette
on va voir si elle arrive à comprendre
une baguette voilà l a compris
merci oui bien sûr les sources ont
besoin de portables comme les entendants
les entendants entendu la sonnerie
mais les sourds n'entendent pas la
sonnerie
par exemple
ah là ça vibre
regardez ça vibre
j'ai un sms ou bien appels en visio
bonjour ça va ça fait longtemps que je
te vois plus tagro si tu manges trop bon
je suis en retard faut que j'y aille au
revoir
vous voyez là j'ai état j'ai besoin de
mon portable
bonjour boulangerie croissant
pains au chocolat pas aux raisins
baguette
portable
merci au revoir
et